okay oh goodness alrighty to you let's
go guys I have always been a little bit
of a daredevil it that's changing now
that I'm a new mom you know I'm
definitely sort of thinking about my
child in his future but yeah I kind of
always like to push the boundaries a
little bit Brooklyn and tennis pro hubby
Andy Roddick became parents last year
that's their infant son Hank with new
mom and dad chrissy teigen and john
legend getting in a little parental
practice and some advice from Brooklyn
the trick is if the baby's crying you
take them outdoors and it's kind of
amazing how when they get outside all of
a sudden they're just in complete wonder
kinda like Brooklyn the sporty Sports
Illustrated supermodel is a Sierra Club
ambassador and her need for speed in the
San Gabriel Mountains is to promote the
National Park Service's 100th
anniversary
I grew up camping and spending time
outdoors and I think that's something
that we're doing less and less these
days it's just good for the soul on his
fun listen Brooklyn is one tough cookie
at the Super Bowl in Dallas we got
caught in a freak ice storm our driver
couldn't see how the windshield he pulls
over on the highway before we blink
Brooklyn rolls down her window hops on
the hood of the car and scrapes all the
ice off the windshield she's like Wonder
Woman and a tough cookie as a measure